[Musique]
ils ont dû faire ça la nuit où il avait
tant plu
[Musique]
je suis évidemment très choquée d'une
part par la profanation en soit 2 des
tombes d'un cimetière le respect dû aux
morts ça remonte à la plus haute
préhistoire
c'est en soi choquant d'autre part
l'utilisation du symbole nazi qu'est la
croix gammée me choque d'autant plus que
fontainebleau a connu beaucoup de
victimes du nazisme
il ya un manque de culture et un manque
de connaissance et qui nécessite qu'on
approfondisse ses questions et qu'on le
fasse savoir
il n'est il faut toujours toujours
toujours témoigné là dessus est toujours
à prendre toujours comprendre c'est
indispensable quoi s'attaquer ici enfin
bon c'est des idiots ou alors ils sont
complices ont ils se vengent de leur
confinement et ils se sont dit allez on
va sur un petit coup de petit peu
d'adrénaline dans le cimetière enfin bon
je vois que ça c'est un manque de
respect de toute façon mais c'est aussi
un manque de connaissance de l'histoire
les gens qui font ça ne savent pas ce
qu'est ce que ce que signifie une croix
gammée
c'est bon c'est choquant c'est
lamentable
voilà c'est incompréhensible pour qu'on
pense
parce que ça représente
organisme donc si on en arrive là c'est
que ça devient très grave